[Laughter]
everything is changing
what do you mean the end is near sal no
i don't i don't know what you mean what
do you mean i don't want to die there's
nothing you can do
the end is near
everything is changing
from the eternal from within no i don't
want to die what do you mean
sorry about that man
[Music]
honey someone's here oh
oh hey
good to see you thanks for having us
this is my girlfriend
we're so happy you could join us and
this is my wife
so this is the infamous
and
has told me so much about you both
all good things i hope
you could never trust
[Music]
and please please don't call me makes me
think my mother's around someplace oh
hey you know where is little
oh
she's at
house for a slumber party
oh oh um
[Music]
there was this is the couple from new
york that we wanted you guys to meet uh
this is
and her husband
uh they're gonna be in new york for a
few weeks so we were hoping you could
give them some tips oh i'm sure oh
that'd be great so how do you know
and
oh well
and i went to
school of dramatic arts back when
was working in midtown
oh where did you work i was at uh
and oh the law firm
oh hey
how are you it's so good to see you
hey everybody this is
[Applause]
i want you to meet one of my dearest
oldest friends
this is his girlfriend
hi
of course you know
this is
and this is her husband
hi
what a beautiful name you know i knew
her
in grad school oh
well thank you but it's actually
pronounced
wow i swear that sounds like what you
were saying
anyways it's lovely to meet you all yes
robert
i'm so sorry hi and rick
i'm
showing myself to the restroom wow
that's so rude oh well
for
sake
[Music]
so
i
am your substitute
mr nostrom
but that might as well say no nonsense
because i
do not
play
now today will not be a day off
in fact today you will work harder than
[Music]
[Music]
oh man i feel like crap just came from a
trashy indian restaurant in a strip mall
not bad food though got pretty lucky got
the hottest baddest curry ever ate in my
life this place called nonsense indian
joint just like terminal 3. it's like
i'm going to my brother's wedding on
sunday and it's like i even want to go i
don't even like my brother my brother's
like a jerk well like his wife she's
like a [ __ ] i stayed with him for like
three weeks she just bitched me man i
put my feet on her coffee table she was
like don't get your feet on my cup i'm
like who are you
a ginger broad man like those are the
worst people on the planet so i said
that too i said that to him in the
parking lot i cornered him a little bit
sure but he swung on me man
he swung on me can you believe that it's
like who swings and their own brother
man yeah i swung back you know
but that's cool you know it's like i
haven't seen him for a while but now got
this expensive wedding i have to go to
so it's crazy i gotta get my
tickets and that's the whole situation i
hate doing that and hold on a second hey
hey help out
[Music]
start on the downstairs bit it's a
middle of a conversation i'm here
thank you
sorry about that a little guy here uh
working on my soup from the eternal
[Music]
yes
and hopefully you know i can get like
two down in one evening you know and
speaking of two down and one anything if
they've got popcorn shrimp and little
lobster rolls
stop
who goes
[Music]
[Laughter]
everything is changing
what do you mean
the end is near sal no i don't i don't
know what you mean what do you mean i
don't want to die there's nothing you
can do
the end is near
everything is changing
from the eternal from within
no i don't want to die what do you mean
[Music]
sorry about that there they've got it
change is coming
[Music]
[Music]
you ready homie hells yeah
we gotta go back home man
why
i poop my pants
just now
i just pulled my pants
you got diarrhea hell no man i ain't gay
we gotta go home right now man let me
change my draw some of the dudes be
trying to smoke is right there man how
you want me to smoke somebody when i got
poop in my pants
are you sure you pooped them am i short
am i short yeah
yes that is poop in my pants nasty man
it's natural man
for a three-year-old not for a hardcore
gangster see my real friend though you
wouldn't make such a big deal out of it
wouldn't make such a big deal out of it
okay you a grown-ass man who just in his
drawers oh snap
no you didn't
get you
pants again don't judge you need to get
out of my car and go to the hospital
okay i see how it see
i wouldn't do that to you though you
never would have to do that to me
because under no circumstances whatever
my pants
i'm sorry i judged you apology accepted
[Music]